In talking about the adaptive
immune system, we've already
seen that there's a
couple of actors.
You have your humoral
response.
So this is responding to things
that are floating
around in the fluids of the
body and not necessarily
things that have infiltrated
your body cells and then you
have your cell mediated
response.
And then in the humoral
response-- and we're talking
about specific humoral
response-- this is where the B
cells, the B lymphocytes are
at their most active.
And essentially what they do
is, you got a B cell here.
It has a very specific antibody,
specific to just
this B cell, not B
cells in general.
If this happens to be the one
of the billions of B cells
that happens to have the
matching key-- or maybe I
should say the matching lock
for the key that is the
intruding pathogen--
that pathogen will
bind to that B cell.
Maybe it's a virus, maybe
it's a bacteria.
And then the B cell will get
activated and we'll talk about
in this video that
the activation
doesn't always happen.
In fact, it usually doesn't
happen just from this, but so
far we've said it gets
activated, it goes into memory
B cells, which are essentially
multiple versions of this
original B cell-- just saying,
hey, let's have multiple
versions of this-- because it
tends to recognize this virus.
So in the future if we get this
virus, those multiple
versions, those memory cells are
going to be there to have
this interaction.
This interaction's going to be
more likely to happen in the
future because I'm going
to have more of this
variety of B cell.
And then you have
effector cells.
And these are essentially-- so
both of these are B cells.
So this guy, once he gets
activated, he proliferates,
keeps dividing and
cloning himself.
The memory cells just stick
around waiting to be activated
in the future.
And I'm only drawing one
of these membrane bound
antibodies, but there are
actually 10,000 on them.
I mean, I could draw
a bunch of these.
I don't have to just draw one.
The memories just wade around
in the future, but there's
more of them now.
So in the future, if we get
this virus again, this
interaction's going to happen
faster and so they're going to
get activated faster.
And then the effector B
cells essentially turn
into antibody factories.
This antibody goes in and it
says, let me just produce--
I've been activated.
Let me produce many,
many more versions
of that exact antibody.
So they get spit out.
I drew that one little wrong.
So that exact antibody, that
can then be spit out to go
disable or tag antigens-- and
not just any antigen-- this
antigen right here.
And we also saw that the other
thing that the B cell does is
it becomes an antigen
presenting cell.
So what it does is, as soon as
it recognizes this, it's had
this interaction with an antigen
that just matches the
variable portion of its membrane
bound antibody.
It endocytosizes that.
It brings that into itself.
It's membrane facilitated so it
just kind of pulls it in,
chunks it up, and then presents
a piece of that
antibody on an MHC
II molecule.
We saw that in the last video.
So it cuts that up and presents
a piece of it right
there and that's why we call it
an antigen presenting cell.
Now in this video, we're going
to talk about why we even have
these MHC II molecules.
What are we presenting
these antigens to?
So we're going to start
talking about the cell
mediated-- and actually, even
more than the cell mediated,
we're going to talk
about T cells.
And I said in the first video,
they're called T cells because
they mature in the thymus.
And there are two types of
T cells and it's all very
confusing because you have B
cells and T cells, but then
there are two types
of T cells.
You have helper T cells-- and
most people just write T with
a lower-case or subscript
h there.
And then you have cytotoxic T
cells-- or T cells that kill
other cells.
Now just so that you have a big,
overarching impression of
what does what-- B cells.
When they are activated, they
generate antibodies.
At 30,000 feet, that's the
best summary of what an
activated B cell does.
It actually generate
antibodies.
Those antibodies attach to
viruses and bacteria and other
types of pathogens and disables
them-- either tags
them so that macrophages can go
and eat them up or just by
throwing all of those antibodies
on to the surface
of the pathogen in question.
It might disable the pathogens
or essentially bundle them
altogether so that it'll be
easier for macrophages to pick
them up, but this is only
effective for things that are
floating around.
Free floating antibodies are
only effective for things that
are floating around.
Cytotoxic T cells, which I'll
cover in more detail in a
future video-- these actually
attack cells that have been
infiltrated.
So this is attack, kill,
infiltrated cells-- and when I
say infiltrated, it could be a
cell that a virus has gone
into or some bacteria
has penetrated it.
And when I say infiltrated, it
doesn't necessarily even mean
something from the outside.
It could even be a cancerous
cell that shows itself to be
abnormal in some way and so the
cytotoxic T cells will at
least attempt to kill them.
But what I want to focus on--
out of the three types of
lymphocytes-- remember,
everything we've been talking
about was leukocytes, white
blood cells, but lymphocytes
are a subset of that and these
three are lymphocytes.
And they're called that because
they began their
development in the
bone marrow.
So this guy and this guy
actually do stuff.
This guy generates antibodies
that attach to pathogens
floating around.
This guy directly attacks
cells that are
broken in some way.
They've either been infiltrated,
they're abnormal,
they're cancerous--
who knows what.
And I'll do a whole video on
that, but that leads us to a
very obvious question.
What does this guy do?
What does the helper T cell
do if he doesn't directly
interface either with pathogens
or produce things
that interface with pathogens--
or if he himself
doesn't go and directly
kill cells?
And the answer is that the
helper T cell's kind of the
alarm of the immune system.
And on some level, it's almost
the most important.
So we talked already in the
last video about antigen
presenting cells-- that either
when a macrophage or a
dendritic cell takes things
in, it cuts them up and
presents it on its surface as
these MHC II proteins or in
complex with these MHC II
complexes or proteins.
And so do B cells.
B cells are more specific.
Now, once something is
presented, now the helper T
cell can come into
the picture.
So this is a-- let me do a
dendritic cell-- and I'm doing
dendritic cells actually on
purpose because dendritic
cells are actually
the best cells at
activating helper T cells.
We're going to talk about in a
second what happens when a
helper T cell gets activated.
So let's say I have this
dendritic cell.
It's called dendritic so
it looks like it has
dendrites on it.
So I have this dendritic
cell here.
It's a phagocyte.
Let's say it's already consumed
some type of bacteria
or virus and it's cut it up and
now it's presenting kind
of the body parts of that virus
on the MHC II complex.
It's kind of its way of saying,
hey, I found this
shady thing floating around
in the body's tissues.
Maybe someone ought
to raise an alarm.
Maybe this is part of some type
of bigger thing going on
and some type of alarm bell
has to be released.
And that's what the helper
T cell does.
So let's say this guy--
he's presented it.
He says, I found this thing.
I killed it.
Here's a part of it.
The helper T cell has a
T cell receptor on it.
Let's say this is the helper
T cell right here.
And it has a T cell receptor on
it and the T cell receptors
bond to-- and I'll be very
particular here.
So this is the T
cell receptor.
It's just like a protein, but
like the membrane bound
antibodies on B cells that every
B cell or almost every B
cell has a different version,
different variable chain,
that's also true of helper T
cells-- that just like the B
cells, this has some variation
in where it binds.
So this right here is going to
be variable from one helper T
cell to another.
For example, I might have
another helper T cell here.
That also has a T cell receptor,
but the variable
portion on that T cell receptor
is different than the
variable portion on this
T cell receptor.
So this helper T cell will not
bind to this dendritic cell or
the MHC II complex of
this dendritic cell.
Only this one would.
And the mechanism of how you
get this variation is very
similar to the mechanism in how
you get the variation on
the antibodies and
the B cells.
During these helper T cells'
development, at some point the
genes that code for this part of
this receptor get shuffled
around and they get shuffled
around intentionally so that
each T cell has a certain
specificity to a combination
of an MHC II complex and a
certain polypeptide, a certain
part of a virus.
So only this guy's going to be
activated, not this guy.
So this is why we call it the
specific immune system.
Now we said, what does
that helper T
cell do at that point?
He said, hey, I happen to be the
one helper T cell that can
bond to this guy, this antigen
that's presented.
It becomes activated.
And I won't go into the details,
but in general,
dendritic cells are the best
ones at activating it,
especially a naive T cell.
In general, when we talk about
a naive B cell or a naive
helper T cell, these are cells
that are non-memory,
non-effector, that have never
been touched by-- they've
never been activated, in
the case of a B cell.
They've never been activated by
something binding to their
membrane bound antibody-- or
a naive helper T cell is a
non-effector, non-memory helper
T cell that's never had
anything bound to it.
So if this guy is naive and then
he finally has a reaction
with this antigen presenting
cell, he becomes non-naive.
He becomes activated and when
activated, two things happen.
Well, just like with B cells,
he proliferates many, many,
many copies of himself and some
subset of those copies
differentiate into
effector cells.
And effector just means
it does something.
It does something now instead
of saving the memory.
And then some subset of them
become memory helper T cells
after getting activated.
Now the memory T cells, just
like memory B cells-- now you
have more copies of this.
So in 10 years in the future,
if something like this
happens, this interaction's
going to be
more likely to happen.
These guys have the same T cell
receptor as their parent.
It's just that the memory T
cells-- or actually even the
memory B cells-- they
last longer.
They don't kill themselves.
They'll last for years so that
if 10 years later, something
like this starts presenting
itself, you're going to have
more of these guys around to
bump into this guy so that you
can raise the alarm bells.
This guy's also going to have
the same chain right there.
So you're saying, fine.
I have these memory cells.
They're going to stick around
so that this reaction can
happen in the future, but I
still haven't answered the
question, what does the
effector T cell do?
What the effector T cell does
is it raises the alarm.
So there's an effector T cell.
It has been activated.
Remember, this is
very particular.
Only this version of T cells,
but once it got activated, it
produced many copies of itself
because it says, hey, I'm
responding to a particular
type of pathogen.
So that this is a
helper T cell.
This is an effector.
And what these do is they
start releasing these
molecules called cytokines.
So they start releasing
cytokines.
There are many, many different
types of cytokines and I'm not
going to go into detail on all
that, but what cytokines do is
that they really raise
the alarm.
So if you have other activated
lymphatic cells or other
activated immunological cells--
when the cytokines
enter those cells-- remember,
cytokines
are really just proteins.
When the cytokines enter-- or
polypeptides-- when they enter
those cells, it makes
them get in gear.
It makes them multiply more
often or it makes them get
more active in their
immune response.
So what this does-- these
cytokines you can view as
chemical alarm bells chemical
or peptide alarm bells alarm
bells it it tells everyone
to get in gear.
So that's one role, and so you
can see this is actually a
very central role and it'll tell
both activated cytotoxic
T cells to get in gear, which
we haven't talked about yet.
And it'll also tell B cells
to keep proliferating.
So when an activated B cell gets
some of-- so this is an
activated B cell.
When it gets some of these
cytokines, that maybe come
from a local helper T cell,
it'll tell it, hey no, divide
more often.
Divide more often.
Only if you've been
activated already.
And we'll talk more about why
it has to be that case,
because you don't want all the
B cells to be activated.
And the other thing that the
effector T cell does-- in the
B cell discussion, I said, OK,
if I have a B cell, and it has
its membrane bound
antibody, has its
membrane bound antibody.
And remember, this is a
particular version, it has its
particular variable
chain right here.
And this guy binds
to a pathogen.
So this binds to a pathogen.
Maybe it's a virus
right there.
Up to now, I've been saying
that this guy's activated.
And he's going to-- well, when
he binds to the pathogen he'll
take this in and he'll take part
of the pathogen and cut
it up and place it on
an MHC II molecule.
And we said, then he'll
be activated.
He'll proliferate and he'll
differentiate into memory and
effector B cells-- but that's
not quite true.
This first stage happens.
This guy bonds.
This B cell happened to be
specific to this virus.
Cuts up the virus.
Puts parts of the virus on its
surface and presents parts of
the antigen.
But in most cases, this B cell
isn't yet activated.
You can kind of view it as in
its resting state, ready to be
activated, but it hasn't started
proliferating and
differentiating into effector
and memory molecules yet.
And in order for that to happen,
an activated helper T
cell that is also specific to
this very same virus-- so you
could imagine someplace else in
the cell-- this virus was
eaten by a dendritic cell.
So this exact same virus, this
exact same species of virus,
is eaten by that dendritic cell
and so the dendritic cell
eats it up, it cuts it up, and
then it presents it-- it's
antigen presenting so it
presents it just like that.
Then this will activate
a very specific T
cell, maybe that one.
So a very specific T cell will
come and bump into it.
Not just any T cell,
the one with the
right variable portion.
So think about what's
happening.
The variable portion for this
T cell, it connects to this
part of the virus plus the MHC
II, but it's really reacting
to the same virus.
It might be a different part.
This little part that was cut
off might be someplace inside
the virus while the epitope for
the B cell might be some
place on the outside of the
virus, but they're both
specific to the same virus.
Now once this guy gets activated
and he starts
producing memory and effector
cells-- or they're descended
from him, one of those effector
cells specific to
this virus are needed to
come bind to this guy.
So then this guy could then go
along and bump around and
eventually end up here.
And he is also specific
to this virus.
So this binding site right
here is the same as this
binding site.
This combination of antigen
plus MHC II.
And so when this guy binds--
and remember, this binding
site is the same as this and
it only binds to this
combination right here-- this
is what activates the B cell
in most cases.
This is T-dependent
activation, which
is usually the case.
Sometimes all you need is this
first thing, but in general
you need the first thing and
then you also need a T cell to
come and activate it, and only
then will the B cell get
activated and start
proliferating and dividing and
differentiating itself and
producing-- when its effector
cells will produce a
lot of antibodies.
And so there's a natural
question.
Why do biological systems--
or why do we
have this double system?
And at least my sense of it is,
it's a failsafe mechanism.
If every time a virus came and
attached this, this guy just
started going crazy and
producing antibodies against
this thing, there's some
chance that maybe after
development, this chain right
here or his genes for
generating these chains become
specific, not for foreign
pathogens, but maybe they
become specific for self
molecules, molecules
that are naturally
produced within the body.
It's just a random mutation, but
if he started going crazy
for that, his antibodies will
start attacking molecules that
are naturally in the body and
then that could really hurt.
That what causes autoimmune
diseases, where your own
immune cells start activating
yourself.
But if you have this double
handshake system where this
has to happen and this has to
happen, the likelihood of both
of these guys after they leave
their development stage
becoming specific to a self
protein or a self cell or a
self molecule is
very unlikely.
So it kind of inhibits this guy
from going wild, even if
he has some type
of a mutation.
Anyway, hopefully that explains
a little bit of what
helper T cells do.
We'll talk a lot
more about it.
I know it can be a little
bit confusing.
In the next video, we'll talk
about cytotoxic T cells.